on vous l'a dit répéter pour se
maintenir en forme il est recommandé de
pratiquer la marche au moins une
demi-heure par jour Michel Berranger
caviste à Montigny-le-Bretonneux est
largement dans les clous il ne se
déplacement qu'à pieds pour se rendre
sur son lieu de travail ou pour aller
manger le midi ce qui représente environ
une heure chaque jour alors pourquoi ce
choix la première chose c'est parce que
je ne conduis pas j'ai pas de permis
donc pas question je pourrais très bien
faire accompagner en voiture ce qui
m'arrive de temps en temps comme mon
domicile est relativement proche du de
mon lieu de travail de mon magasin donc
il y a aucun problème selon cette ini
Montin même s'il avait son permis il
continuerait de pratiquer cette activité
physique qu'il vente qu'il pleuve ou
qu'il neige au cours de ces
pérégrinations matinales Michel se plait
à rêver et à planifier sa journée dans
l'ensemble dans son quartier il estime
que les axes sont suffisamment bien
aménagés pour les piétons il n'a qu'un
seul reproche à faire quelquefois oui
effectivement je suis irrité parce que
comment dirais-je
les passages protégés en général sont
pas forcément respectées malheureusement
et on se rend compte que il y a pas
beaucoup de gens qui marchent il y a
beaucoup de gens en voiture pour
quelques enveloppes mais c'est surtout
pour la voiture et il y a très peu de
gens qui marchent on a un peu le
sentiment que le piéton est pas
forcément toujours respecté il n'allait
pas lui parler d'écologie à 66 ans
Michel n'a pas attendu la révolution
verte pour se mettre à marcher pour info
selon le STIF les Franciliens
consacreraient 1h20 quotidiennement pour
se rendre au travail contre 17 minutes
en moyenne en province d'après une étude
publiée par l'Observatoire de la
mobilité la marche à pied arrive en tête
des modes de déplacement en
Île-de-France tout type de trajet
confondu la voiture arrive en second
suivi des transports collectifs